[Music]
katie is in springfield hi katie welcome
to the ramsay show
hello can you hear me thank you for
having me sure what's up
so i am a newlywed college student and
my husband and i
are about 12 000 a little bit over in
debt and are trying to figure out how to
get
ahead of this ball before it gets bigger
than what we can pay off reasonably
right after school
you're twelve thousand dollars in debt
yes and you're what you're in school
um so i have full red and i'm finishing
my associates my husband has also
finished his associates but he's
finishing his bachelor's in engineering
and how are we paying for all of this
future education
so right now we're working and we have
scholarship and then all of my leftover
scholarship since i'm at a really cheap
community college goes over to his bills
for school
so you're not adding any more debt
so that's what we're trying to avoid is
adding any more debts that's what i was
asking about student loan options but we
don't want to take them if we don't have
to you don't have to don't take them
you need to you need to draw a line in
the sand and say no more debt
so that's the first thing and then once
you do that then twelve thousand dollars
you can knock out you may have to wait
until you graduate and get jobs to be
able to knock it out but your first goal
is not getting rid of the 12 000 your
first goal is graduate without any more
debt
and so i would just pile up money until
he graduates
and i'd pay off the 12 000 after he gets
out of school
okay
yeah because right now getting both of
you through with no more debt is a big
job in and of itself isn't it
yes that's enough to concentrate on and
i think that's a great goal and i think
it's very doable by the way
but you do have to take what we say take
debt off the table
if you go that's not an option i'm not
going to do that now how are we going to
figure it out and then that means
scholarships and all the stuff you've
been doing you've been scratching and
clawing and scraping and scrapping and
hustling and grinding and you're doing
all the right stuff you're doing a lot
of smart things here
but the only thing i would tell you is a
take debt off the table b
um
you're if you if you can simply graduate
with no debt
no more debt and deal with the 12 000
later i'm gonna call that a success
wouldn't you i would because again i
think we've been illustrating this hour
certainly that you can pay off twelve
thousand dollars certainly two people
together in this job economy you could
knock that out so fast it really make
your head spin how quickly you could
knock that out i might get that as a
signing bonus at the new job mike that's
right especially with that engineering
degree who knows i mean yeah they're
both going to make good money
here's what's interesting in north
america today
there are
legitimate
areas of poverty where people literally
have
unbelievable poverty
nowhere near what there used to be
it's the best it's ever been poverty
level is the is the lowest it's ever
been in american history right now
and uh but aside from someone living at
that
personal finance is 80 behavior
it's only 20 head knowledge
none of you listening really have a math
problem
as much as you have a behavior problem
and that includes me
when i discovered this truth years ago i
figured out if i could get the guy in
the mirror to behave he could be skinny
and rich
but he's got issues with donuts
chocolate covered preferably yeah he's
got other issues with other kinds of
foods pizza yeah yeah
it could it could be a problem oh yeah
and you know we all have this issue of
you know denying ourselves something now
to get something better later yeah
this idea of delayed pleasure which is a
grown-up act children do what feels good
adults devise a plan and follow it
and so
you know our caller before the break 200
000 a year 85 000 in income that's a
fairly easy math formula you should be
out of debt in two years but you have to
be willing to deeply
sacrifice and oh by the way they've been
living not on two hundred thousand
they've been living on about 250 000
because they've run up over a hundred
thousand dollars worth of credit card
debt
and so um
not only do you have to cut your
lifestyle down to your income now you
have to cut it dramatically below your
income
none of that is a math problem that's
all just a decision and the
rationalizations the beliefs that we've
brought in as to what is normal and our
level of work ethic uh how much are we
willing to work short term and long term
and am i willing to stay at a job that
quote unquote feels secure when there's
something i can make twice as much
with a reasonable level of risk yeah
well you're really hitting on something
i say this all the time dave
that we are as humans
our natural human condition is to be
more comfortable being miserable than
comfortable
than miserable being comfortable right
it's like well we would rather be
miserable than uncomfortable is a better
way to say it yeah because like i know
what my misery is
the devil i know yeah i got the credit
card payments we're barely making ends
meet but we got all the stuff and it's
killing me but i'm used to it versus
what would it take to actually pay off
85 000 what would it take how quickly
could we do it and we don't even dive
into that question
and so what happens is dave the unknown
is terrifying it is absolutely paralyzed
like walking in a cave you and
you and uh daniel ramsey were telling me
the other day a story about being in
israel in some cave or something where
it finally wigged you out because it was
so like dark or something or so crazy
crowded that people wouldn't get out of
there always crouch
but if you've ever been in a dark cave
where you can't see in front of you yeah
you you don't move i can handle that as
long as i got a light yeah mean no i'm
saying but imagine how terrifying here
is an example it's overwhelming well
yeah but you get in a
deep fog what do you do you pull the car
over immediately you can't see behind
the hood of your car
you are out of control
and you can't see your way towards
control it cause it's called anxiety
right that's what we call it but part of
this is we don't even look into what
would be ha what would have to be true
for us to do this and then when we dive
into the unknown a little bit and get
some answers now what was terrifying and
intimidating is oh all right it's gonna
be hard but it's doable yeah
uh jim collins wrote the book good to
great talks about that and great by
choice yeah uh he said the thing that
that
paralyzes more people in business and
it's true in your personal life too
people are more afraid of ambivalence
yes than they are known struggle
absolutely right they'll choose known
struggle over not knowing yes
quicker and so that's what we do here we
shine a light of knowing and go you can
do this now now you got to face the most
difficult equation of all the human
equations you personal finance is 80
behavior it's only 20 percent of
knowledge it is truly up to
you it's not up to the white house it's
up to what happens in your house